in a world full of danger we need heroes
with extraordinary powers
world / fear one man must stand alone
Will Smith Ryan Reynolds Catherine
zeta-jones Dobie Joe Graham Norton's
pants rated on
you saw but we celebrated some super
Horrors in our audience before you came
in I there was a lady with the tsunami
tongue or some Wiggly ears tsunami - oh
can we get a bit of light salt you move
you get a little bit you need to see you
soon ami tongue this is good this is
good
no dishonesty this not gonna get wet no
no good night
ensuring this is serene
this is tsunami turn off you go no let
better focus let it focus it's not it
not easy
mmm look at that inside her mouth asleep
at your wedding
how did you meet cute story now Tom
Adelson you have fan off at such
specific fan art it's a lot yeah and it
does it all come for this one scene
right right yeah yes there's there's a
scene in a first war film where mice I'm
trying to attack Thor Chris Hemsworth as
Thor with this fear and I jump in the
air and he dug he dodges out the way and
I bring the spear down and it wedges
itself into the floor and then I Lee use
the user to spin myself around and kick
him in the chest which has been
interpreted by fans as a demonstration
of my hidden talent at pulled up all
dares yeah yeah no activity there's so
much of this but this is just one
example of Loki really going for it on
the pole
let's see it with the girls voice
I want to treat one or some like it is
terrific it does such a good job with
this movie our people will not be
disappointed it's just fantastic all the
character quite a develop and move on
and the Hulk though moves in a strange
direction in that the hope finds romance
in this film with Thor no one saw it
happening no you saw it at boiler alert
why don't you be embarrassed
God looks like a lot of dieting and
exercise but also for now apparently is
this true the people this is odd so
people come up to you and they want you
to tell a specific joke oh they'll just
come and tell me for a joke
oh okay like um yeah go uh you know the
joke about the Thor spends a night with
this woman and the next morning he says
I have to tell you who I am
you know I'm Thor she says you're Thor I
can hardly walk the first time
twenty-seven
and also what's great is to reflect like
that that poster but also you've done
other posters oh man on or the marketing
of this movies been so much fun it's how
you resolves in this thing completely we
love it we're like giddy lis texting and
e-mailing each other in the middle of
the night like what if we tried this the
emoji poster I love the emoji be after
that is pretty great Deadpool but just
like as a joking text message between me
and a couple of the people and then the
Fox Martin II guess we're gonna make
that of a billboard said you don't have
a balls to make and also you haven't
forgotten that it's opening Valentine's
weekend of course yeah
so yeah who bought that never died yeah
when you got to set you were a bit like
that you were kind of fan Girling romney
yeah we shot ant-man and but I was alone
on that I was like working in a in a
bubble pretty much and then all of a
sudden I'm standing around and seeing
Robert Downey jr. and the Iron Man suit
and seeing Chris Evans and they're all
there I've seen the movies and I felt
like I was I was 10 years old it was
crazy
oh did you read you the touching the
arms but yeah yeah I saw eyes I saw
Sebastian Stan getting his arm the
silver arm on and it was whit I was like
I was watching somebody bathing I'm not
supposed to see this but I did I went
over and I could contain a fell PR man
Chris Evans had to run to the bathroom
really quick so he asked the prop guy it
was could you just hold this he was
holding his shield he ran off huh
here than I imagined oh it's made of
vibranium of course it's gonna be in
yeah yeah
come on Michael Michael Michael come on
we've gotta shoot Michael
is the story true about your parents
Marco yes yeah so so when did you tell
them the lie well it was shortly before
the premiere of the film I decided to
come clean and tell them that I yeah it
was like no you don't know well well
then they start well then I well first I
started off with there is no I didn't
mention the nudity and then I heard
there was nudity so then they said that
they CGI'd my head onto someone else's
body
yeah there's a Jurassic Park yeah and
and then eventually I told them it was
me I'm with you okay with this
yeah I took a really well okay guys I
have a daughter and you got you kind of
want to know that before you in the
theater yeah
we've got some unicycles here we've got
to be unicycle said so you can do this
hey define can recognize we'll see no
yeah okay the visual
be right back guys and go say hi to the
Star Wars dudes and I approach their
table it was like nice
they just pull yourself together